my thing was I wanted to learn the
difference between fear and intuition
right yeah I was right God damn it it's
such a hard one I think when we get
stuck on the fear and intuition we we
fear making a bad decision right I don't
want to make a bad decision I said you
know what instead of putting so much
pressure on myself to know that this is
intuition that I'm making because
intuition is the right decision right so
instead of putting so much pressure on
myself to like is this intuition I just
said I'm gonna go with energy feels good
right and if something scares me but I
know I should do it I'm going to do it
and I'm going to parent myself through
it right to help myself and letting go
of the need to have all the decisions be
right and correct in my life